Apple's 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pros are
regarded by some as being the best
laptops ever made and now we're getting
rumors that apple is about to refresh
them again with some new upgrades except
there is a little bit of controversy
because I myself for the last few months
I've been telling you guys that I
believe these new Macbook Pros are
coming with new three nanometer M2 Pro
and M2 Max chips Against All Odds and
against what other people have been
saying but it's not only me because
other sources like digitimes Jeff Pooh
and taiwan's Commercial times have said
that these new M2 Pro chips will be
three nanometer so the big question is
this was I wrong and are these other
sources wrong well that's a difficult
question to answer and we're going
through it in this video my actual take
is that the M2 Chip is going to be
coming to the iPad Pro and Mac Mini this
fall however over the M2 Pro and Max are
coming to the new 14 and 16 inch MacBook
Pros this spring of 2023 that is what I
fully believe based on tsmc announcing
that they're starting mass production of
their three nanometer chips later this
year and they're going to be available
in January of 2023 but I also gave a few
more reasons on Twitter for why I
believe these new Macbook Pros are
coming in the spring instead of the Fall
first of all there's an 18-month gap
between the original M1 ship and the M2
so that would match up perfectly with
the M1 Pro and Max MacBook Pros coming
out in October of 2021 with an 18 month
Gap bringing us to Spring of
2023. another reason is because I
believed that the new Mac Mini would get
fully redesigned and apple was only
showing off one redesigned product per
event and I believe that they're gonna
show off a redesigned back Mini at their
fall October event but things actually
changed I'm going to show you guys why
in just a minute and my last reason was
that a 12-month cycle is just not giving
Apple enough time to update and make all
of their products better across all of
their apple silicon Macs they just don't
have enough time to upgrade each product
every year with new skus with new colors
and everything it's just not enough time
so that's why an 18-month cycle makes
more sense and that is why I believe
that if they come out in Spring they
could easily come with a new three
nanometer chips from tsmc however this
past month everything changed we just
got the new iPhone 14 pro and that has
the new a16 ship which everybody thought
was going to stick to the same five
nanometer fabrication as before and
that's what makes you quote said but it
turns out that the a16 is now coming
with the new 4 nanometer process now
before I move on our sponsor keyspan
offers cheap and legal 100 genuine OEM
software keys with online activation and
they have 24 7 customer service for a
lifetime after you purchase making it an
excellent opportunity to renew your
operating system and improve performance
and security so use the links below for
up to 50 to 62 off Windows and Microsoft
Office software now some would argue
that the new a16 chip is actually just
an a15 plus even saying that Apple could
just reuse the same fabrication because
it is so similar and in that case Ming
chikuo is correct however it's been
reported that tsmc has been pricing
Apple's a16 bionic 2.4 times higher than
its predecessor the a15 yes 2.4 times
more expensive which is crazy which kind
of means that there are some other
differences to make this new four
nanometer process more expensive and
then here's the bigger issue apparently
tsmc's three nanometer Wafers are even
more expensive like insanely expensive
which is one reason why Apple might just
stick to four nanometer on these MacBook
Pros instead of going to three because
they might have to raise their prices
even higher and tsmc is already getting
their three nanometer process ready for
example they've already started mass
production this year but still people
are reporting that the M2 Pro and empty
Max chips are gonna be on three
nanometer despite a16 bionic staying on
four nanometer and despite the M2 being
on five this is just a mess and then
late August Michi quo said that tsmc's
three nanometer chips won't be ready in
time for 2022 MacBook Pros which I also
believe and that's why I thought they're
going to be coming in the springtime
however he says what if these new
Macbook Pros do come later this year
because a lot of people are saying
they're coming like for example Mark
German believes they're also coming
later this year and then where it gets
even more interesting is that digit
times back in March believed that the
first M2 Max would be launching on the
four nanometer chip process which they
didn't they were still five nanometers
so what if Apple chose to stick with
five nanometer for the M2 but they're
going to be going for four nanometer for
the M2 Pro and M2 Max instead because
they're more expensive well I do want to
add that I interviewed Mark German on
this channel and he completely disagreed
with my theory thinking that these new
Macbook Pros would be based on the three
nanometer process he believes that
they're most likely going to be five
nanometer just like the M2 Chip and he
even said that there's a chance that we
might not even get an Apple October
event but still get those new products
like the new Mac Mini the new Macbook
Pros and the iPad Pros would just press
releases which kind of points to them
being very disappointing upgrades
because they're not worthy of an Apple
event which likely means it might just
be spec updates but what it all comes
down to is the Mac Mini because during
that interview he says he believes the
Mac Mini is not getting any redesigned
at all the same exact chassis but not
only that he says it's going to come
with the option of the M2 Chip or the M2
Pro which is very very important because
if the M2 Pro chip is available this
month in the Mac Mini that likely means
that they also have to release the
MacBook Pros at the same time with the
M2 Pro and M2 Max chips because that's
what Apple did in the past they released
both of the chips at the same time in
the MacBook Pros and adding more
evidence to that claim we actually have
a Mac Rumors Forum user amethyst who
believes that the M2 Mac Mini is an
incremental upgrade with the same design
the same Parts just changing the soc and
the threads which that key point right
there means it could have different ship
options M2 and M2 Pro exactly what Mark
German is saying and if this ends up
being true that likely means that the
MacBook Pros are not getting delayed
until spring and they're not getting
three nanometer chips they're either
getting the same five nanometer or the
updated four nanometer process which
actually could make sense because Apple
could use that for marketing they could
say Hey look it's the new four nanometer
it's a nice upgrade even though it's not
that that big of a difference and it's
nowhere near as good as how the three
nanometer chance will perform however is
it possible that Apple could release the
Mac Mini with the M2 and the M2 Pro but
delay the MacBook Pros until the spring
and not reveal the M2 Max chip until
then what if the M2 Max is built on
three nanometer because it's a higher
end chip who knows that's probably very
unlikely so with all that said if we add
in all the supply chain issues we had
the inflation problem that we have and a
potential recession coming up it might
actually make more sense for Apple to
give us a disappointing and very modest
spec update on the 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pro later this month and that
way it's really going to be meant for
people who did not choose to upgrade to
the M1 Pro and M1 Max MacBook Pros but
now that it's refreshed maybe the will
add the new midnight color it might
convince some people to upgrade but I do
not think that it's going to be worth
any existing 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pro
owners to upgrade it's just not going to
be that big of a difference and in that
case if that ends up happening then I
would have been wrong the entire time
about three nanometer and apple would
just push that another year or year and
a half later and they'll make more money
when they introduce that and convince
more people to upgrade Apple knows what
they're doing and they can stretch out
their technology as far as they want to
because their laptops are ahead of the
game and they know it so Apple doesn't
have to give us the best of the best
soon with three nanometer they can just
stretch it out and delay it so that's
disappointing but it's the most likely
outcome so if you disagree with any of
my takes in this video go ahead and
comment down below and if you enjoyed
the video click the search Circle above
to subscribe and check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]